تحت شمس ولايه تكساس الدافئه يقود ترامب
حملته الانتخابيه بعيدا عن القضبان واروقت
المحاكم بعد ان اكد مسبقا نيه المحكمه في
اعتقاله واغراقه بالتهم يواجه ترامب اليوم
تهمه الحريه بعد ان ذهب بعيدا باثارته
الفوضى ولعبه على عاطفه الانصار يقول
الديمقراطي بعيدا عن محكمه منهتا نجح
الرئيس السابق في جمع الالاف من انصاره
لكن ترامب المتهم تقع على هويه ترومبا
المترشح
مدعي نيويورك العام مدفوعا بتعليمات
تلقاها من وزير العدل في واشنطن قام
بالتحقيق حول قضيه لا تعد جريمه ولا حتى
مخالفه وهو يغادر تكساس اكد ان محكمه
نيويورك بصدد اسقاط القضيه اعلانات كاذبه
سوء استخدام اموال الحمله الانتخابيه
عشرات القضايا المماثله ان لم تكن
قد تعود الى الواجهه مع ارتفاع حمى
الانتخابات لكن ترامب يولي اهميه الطريق
العوده الى البيت الابيض اكثر من بناء
برنامج انتخابي لم يتغير منذ سنوات انه
امر فريد حير خبراء القانون لقد راقبوا
احد عشر مليون صفحه من المستندات ولم
يجدوا شيئا ضدي لقد انشات شركه رائعه ربما
يجعلني هذا الرجل الاكثر براءه في تاريخ
بلدنا
القضاء الامريكي تحول الى اهم خصم يعيق
عوده
وفي انتظار ذلك يتسلح المتهم بانصاره
وقبليتهم لغزو الشوارع من اجل ضمان حريه
ترامب المترشح